hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you
oh Jesus that took a lot of energy right
there you probably build cheese she
sounded so [ __ ] old the past couple
of weeks kid what happened I'll tell you
what happened old freckles is off the
road yes the old [ __ ] [ __ ] he ate
what he used to be
ain't what he used to be ain't I love it
I ain't doing [ __ ] [ __ ] it's all
[ __ ] call me I'll tell you right if I
had the [ __ ] if we weren't in a
never-ending 17 [ __ ] wars right now
and they weren't [ __ ] taking such a
giant [ __ ] I literally give these
[ __ ] more than I make and I huh Uncle
Sam going onstage telling any [ __ ]
jokes ah the big he's like a [ __ ]
character comic that's what he would be
this big stupid [ __ ] hack you know
going up there so he's on a [ __ ]
unicycle
I want you yeah I want you to go [ __ ]
yourself how about that Sammy how about
I get to keep just a little just how
about a [ __ ] hair more sorry anyways
what am i thankful for this weekend I'll
tell you right now dude if if there was
a if there was a [ __ ] way that I
could figure out if I could figure out
how to get off the [ __ ] hamster wheel
you know because the deal is it's like
you keep running or we're just gonna tax
the [ __ ] out of you you want to put your
[ __ ] money on the crap table we'll
give you a little break you know but if
you hit well like the second you start
slowing down you know the government's
just like wait does this [ __ ]
think he's gonna retire he's just gonna
coast you're gonna get in that [ __ ]
car when you're going to work who's
welcome future [ __ ] and you're gonna
[ __ ] work and then we're gonna take
more than you [ __ ] make
you can work good Hey smarten up that's
what they should do just come in like
that [ __ ] guy they're in casino smart
nothing buddy take your head and I stick
it through that [ __ ] hole that's
basically their vibe so anyways I
figured out how to retire I saw it today
and I was walking out of the grocery
store so this guy had a Ford f-150 with
the camper on the back and I'm like
that's it right there they'll let you do
that you don't want to work then you got
to live like that I write your [ __ ] and
we're still gonna give you tickets and
eventually we're gonna tow your house
away hey if you are in that situation if
they show up can you take the camper off
the back and then they just take the
truck
you know you probably couldn't in a bit
well yeah you're gonna have to move that
any [ __ ] you're getting underneath it
like those old-school guys that put the
refrigerators on their back and you got
to [ __ ] start traipsing down the
street you know man you set it up and
then some douche with the house like me
it's just like um have you seen the guy
down the street with the camper I don't
want that in my neighborhood anyways
what I'm trying to say is I really enjoy
time off I've been having a great time
just hanging with my daughter hanging
with my wife threw down yesterday you
know all the relatives came over
everybody [ __ ] ate but old freckles I
didn't go too hard didn't go too hard I
stayed away from the desserts you know I
I did pretty good then this morning I
woke up I had my little parfait butter
right I had the [ __ ] you know a
little bit of Greek yogurt with the
fruit in there like the big fruit cake
that I am and then I had a little hummus
wrap for lunch in between I'm having a
fruit with nuts you know it's holidays
they get me finally figured it out after
50 [ __ ] holidays finally figured it
out wow this is the problem I gotta go
easy I got to go easy this Thanksgiving
weekend alright I had my Thanksgiving
dinner I had it you know around 3:00 in
the afternoon I was halfway through the
plate and I was already leaning oh it
was good
oh it was delicious
and you know you put your plate together
I'm not what I hate those [ __ ] people
is I can't have my food touch other food
you know the only thing worse than the
person saying that is the [ __ ] meat
head across the table why right both of
those people should get in a car and
drive off a cliff no come on bill you
should give thanks for both of them
anyways I don't give a [ __ ] about that
but I will say this when you put
together your Thanksgiving plate this is
how it has to be this is how I do it all
right about four o'clock you got your
turkey okay
three o'clock you got your potatoes that
way you can put the gravy on both all
right and then get it at five o'clock
you know you want your let me move those
all up an hour I'd say five o'clock Stu
turkey four o'clock is the mashed
potatoes six o'clock is your cranberry
sauce you know gives it a little nice
little sweet kick with the gravy and the
turkey get your potatoes in that's good
the [ __ ] vegetable you know that
somebody made that you just try to make
them feel good you know yeah that [ __ ]
all goes up around 12:00 noon that [ __ ]
that you're gonna be like [ __ ] I still
got two more mouthfuls of that all of
that shit's up top that casserole thing
that your [ __ ] aunt makes you know
make sure you get some cash flow with
your [ __ ] itchy sweater right then
what I got what else is left then you
get whatever's like the sweet [ __ ] I
keep around you know that's around 11
o'clock somebody made some yams or
something like that sweet potatoes of
some [ __ ] like that you put that up
there and then you got your bread
somewhere around 8:30 9 o'clock you know
what I mean
and then right in the middle I don't
know what else that's some of the
[ __ ] thing you just stick right in
the middle ah and then you just you just
you eat it like the way your tuna snare
drum
any drummers out they if you know the
whatever there's a million different
patterns but that's basically the way
you do it and I want to just take some
time here to say how bad I feel for
people who don't live in the United
States of America so you don't have this
holiday but you can sit down and eat way
more than your [ __ ] chair oh it's
great
Thanksgivings [ __ ] awesome and kiss
you know why cuz then you got the Friday
off to just lay around you know with
your belly pokin out of the bottom of
your [ __ ] sweater that you passed out
in you know I actually you know I
actually was had to like I'm one of
these lunatics so I'm just like I try to
like make sure everything [ __ ] gets
on the table it's all hot it's all ready
to go I finally realized this year it's
just like there's just too many [ __ ]
people cooking it's just gonna come the
way it goes or whatever and then I
realize anything that needs to be hot
you just put gravy on it's gonna [ __ ]
heat it up again and it was probably the
best Thanksgiving I've had in years
but what's great is the Friday after the
Friday after like today you don't have
to go to work hopefully you know you get
to lounge around you know bleary-eyed
from whatever the [ __ ] you did the night
before and then tomorrow you got all the
college football games what do we got
what do we got tomorrow come on people
you got Michigan Ohio State to kick off
the day you got Alabama versa up and
watch you're not gonna be a good game
this year but you know who knows if I'll
burn wins that I mean Jesus Christ they
they be going [ __ ] nuts I mean
tomorrow is the day you're not a man
tomorrow unless you're ignoring your
family okay that's the level of football
that's I'm kidding but I got my kid you
heard my kid oh she says it now she goes
football football now she wants now she
wants it to be on the TV I'm [ __ ] I'm
staring her away from she always wants
to see Minnie Mouse she goes Mimi Mao
Mimi Mao sounds like she's in uh Mimi
Mao be me Mao like what's that was it
the deer hunter Wow Wow right me me me
me me Wow no me
mouse went to sleep Mimi Mao have I lost
my mind what the [ __ ] am I talking about
I don't know I have no idea how much
time have I done 8 minutes and 45
seconds Jesus Christ some days you know
this podcast flies by and then other
days feels like I did eight hours in 45
minutes
yeah Michigan Ohio State Michigan they
gotta get it done I can't believe this
is already the fifth [ __ ] time
they've played Ohio State with Jim
Harbaugh unless I'm wrong I have no idea
but it's gonna be a great game
I like Big Ten football it's you know
it's old school football you know they
actually run the [ __ ] ball I gotta
tell you that [ __ ] and I don't want to
be a grumpy old man here that [ __ ]
game Monday night Kansas City vs. the
rims the amount of people that were
freaking out though that game was a [ __ ]
show that game remind me of the Super
Bowl last year and I think that that's
basically the direction NFL football is
going in whether it's just going to be
no [ __ ] defense in my favorite thing
about me saying there's no defense
people oh yeah that's just like just
like last year last year the Super Bowl
excuse me there was a fumble that won
the [ __ ] game it's like the [ __ ]
Rams gave up almost 500 yards [ __ ]
passing there was almost a thin six
touchdowns but got room for six
touchdowns and [ __ ] 500 [ __ ] yards
basically there was a total of like 10
passing touchdowns it was over almost a
thousand yards cuz I think that went
over a thousand yards combined it was a
[ __ ] joke
and then everybody say to me oh god bill
you don't you talking about you're just
worried about your Patriots which is
hilarious my Patriots have been thriving
during this era we haven't had a [ __ ]
defense since 2004 a lights-out win the
game 20 to 17 defense we haven't we've
had to [ __ ] score like 35 [ __ ]
points to win a goddamn game
since forever I'm just saying like if
you're gonna sit there and act like this
is just me - Richard Sherman was
tweeting about it another guy on the
[ __ ] Texans it even Tedy Bruschi
actually I actually saved his I did a
screen saw shot of what he basically
said the way the game is now Richard
Sherman's like all they all they want to
see is points because what that does is
that gets the casual fan and the people
that don't understand football who said
oh no blue I mean that's what to be
honest with you if if soccer ever wanted
to make it into America they should be
doing what at the NFL is done to their
game which is just I don't know what
they just took think about it every era
right there's been a Jack Lambert then
there was an L or instyler I'm just
picking some of the guys I can I can off
the top of my head Ray Lewis you know
Ronnie Lots Mike Haynes Lester Hayes
[ __ ] lunatic you know Andre Tippit's
just lights out Bruce Smith's like where
are those guys now this like maybe three
of them and then not putting up the
[ __ ] stats those guys used to put up
you know they just I don't know these
Revis Island there's just not that guy
anymore
they can't they can't like those guys
wouldn't be that guy today all right
they'll shut the [ __ ] up no but I'm just
I'm just [ __ ] saying alright alright
his his Tedy Bruschi welcome to the new
NFL when it comes to defensive football
former linebacker Tedy Bruschi wrote on
twitter offense will move the ball in
score that's it they're gonna move the
ball in score you can't do anything
about it he goes make a handful of plays
a game to take the ball away and get
your offense a couple of extra
possessions score on defense is an A+
it hurts to write that all right so I'll
you fantasy football playing [ __ ] guy
if you're gonna [ __ ] sit there and
say I'm wrong about this then you're
saying Tedy Bruschi is wrong I hate it
I hate it I hate everything that they've
done I hate that that there's no two
line pass and hockey anymore I hate that
it's just these stretch passes up and
down the [ __ ] rink it's just that
everything's like you know what and I
think it's probably cause of like
smartphones and everybody's [ __ ]
looking at all the videos that you need
to sit there like a [ __ ] I don't know
a gerbil that forgot its jacket trying
to think of some animal that shakes I
don't know but don't listen to me I'm
just saying dude that [ __ ] the Holmes
guy is a [ __ ] star alright but you
know they both look like Dan Marino that
night okay and there's only one [ __ ]
Dan Marino that looked like Dan Marino
verse [ __ ] Dan Fouts way back in the
day and those two guys I mean I'm not
saying they won't eventually be there
but like I can't imagine what Marino and
Dan Fouts would have done to those in
today's era you know they threw for for
400 yards a [ __ ] game three four
hundred yards a [ __ ] game back when
you could actually cover a receiver
borderline beat the [ __ ] out of him as
he's going down you could [ __ ] up a
quarterback you could sack a quarterback
and then like actually they lose yardage
rather than the team with the court of
the offense you know getting a first
down because you tackled the guy too
[ __ ] hard I don't like it I don't
like it
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] football you know
it's just you know I get it I get it
people get [ __ ] hurt but uh I don't
know just listening to those [ __ ]
announces going this digital higher
scored and then not even addressing the
level that the game has changed whatever
it's a [ __ ] show it's a goddamn show
and I'm an old man and I said what I
said I'm just gonna go to like I don't
know I'm gonna [ __ ] I start watching
rugby or something something where the
guy with the ball is going to get
[ __ ] tackled I would love to do a
podcast and interview some great
defensive players and just see what
they're thinking about this [ __ ]
and how they think that they would do
it's changed that much but like I said
there's always you know the older
generation never likes the new the new
[ __ ] but you got guys now who literally
are still playing in the league tweeting
saying it's [ __ ] up so I want to think
that I'm right but whenever I talk like
this I always there was at NFL Films if
anybody can find the clip please tweet
it to me there was this guy you know he
was this old-school you know middle
linebacker or something like that it's
like back during the Sam Huff days
and they asked him hey what do you think
about some of the kids playing football
today and he just goes
they wouldn't watch you a football kid
gave you almost [ __ ] had a stroke so
maybe I'm doing that but I just baseball
is still [ __ ] baseball man so you got
you know still got a [ __ ] hit it over
the fence they got rid of the roids I
think I don't know but like the NBA it's
like nobody's allowed to stand
underneath even on defense you got to
get the [ __ ] out of there and just I
don't know guys go in if they start
driving from the three-point line and
people would just get in the [ __ ] out of
them I love when the guy goes up to dunk
and the guy thinks about blocking and
he's like oh I don't end up on Instagram
and he tries to kind of duck out of the
picture and then the bench goes nuts and
they're waving towels at it at an
uncontested dunk in my done complaining
I think I am I think I am hey everybody
the 7th annual Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit tickets are going fast thank you
guys thank you so much the lineup it's
good he was sorry it's gonna be Tuesday
February 19th 2019 at 7 p.m. at the City
Center Theater 131 West 55th Street New
York New York one Double L one night the
lineup is big Jay oakerson Chris Red
safest sounds Gary Gulman Jim Gaffigan
Michelle wolf rich Voss and yours truly
with more names to be announced we're
waiting for people's availabilities and
that type of stuff like you know
obviously
comics working for free giving up their
free time so people are trying to work
it out with their schedules but uh just
an overwhelming response thank you guys
so so much like I said it's the best
thing that I do all year it's been
helping his family incredibly so thank
you so much for that and with that the
old ball the old bald freckles he ain't
what he used to be I miss a lights-out
defensive huh that's all I'm saying
remember the [ __ ] doomsday defense
against the Steel Curtain you know but
no-name defense the over-the-hill gang
the sack exchange the 46 defense and how
much fun was it to watch the [ __ ]
Bears that year with Wilbur Gary fencing
Mike Singletary Richard dent I mean they
they whatever they were [ __ ]
unbelievable lights [ __ ] out defense
I don't know why people don't like
watching that you know hyper
high-powered offense against a great
defense watch that chest mass instead of
having just like [ __ ] free-for-all I
felt like I was watching somebody play
like one of those bar games you know
those people when they throw the basket
the basket ball into the basket and
those people get so good they can use
either either hand that's the way they
were [ __ ] scoring we get it built all
right
helix everybody you ever wake up in the
morning with regrets of what you'd done
replaying the terrible decisions you
made the previous night over and over
and over this my inner voice the kicking
sweating yelling or whatever else you
did to piss everyone in the bedroom off
well guess what but deciding to sleep on
a shitty mattress is your choice
buying a bouquet but Bill buying a
mattress is so hard where would I begin
they're literally writing this for me
well you're in luck buddy because helix
sleep the mattress I've been yelling at
you to buy for almost two years will
change your life just go to hellix leap
calm slash bar take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to the
perfect mattress I can't even [ __ ]
how big do I have to make the print I'm
one of those guys I'm never getting
glasses I think glasses are for [ __ ]
weak people or people that have are
strong enough to admit that they have a
problem I don't know where I am on that
side of the fence I don't know if I'm a
hero or if I'm a coward
it's like tinder for finding a mattress
I just had a large it all the fun with
nah with none of the next morning
regrets and misery and right now you can
get up to 125 dollars off your mattress
order at helix sleep dot-com / / they
have a 100 night trial free shipping and
won't send you creepy next day text
that's that's helix sleep calm / / for
125 dollars off your mattress helic
sleep calm atli ex sleep calm / burn all
right I am NOT getting glasses I'm just
gonna wait some day when there's an
affordable robot I'll just have that
[ __ ] [ __ ] read for me how vulnerable
what will I be you know did you see that
can you know cuz the thing will be
[ __ ] smarter than I am and then I
also I can't see how soon before that
thing [ __ ] brains me with something
in the kitchen do you guys see that
commercial I think it's for Sprint you
know with that guy who sold out he used
to be with Verizon you know and then
they fired him and then he [ __ ] you
know he's like the Henry Hill a [ __ ]
wireless service he [ __ ] you know he
jumps over with Sprint so they're doing
this this thing with this lady's going
to take a picture and she's just talking
about how clear it is and it's three
people in a [ __ ] robot for whatever
reason and the lady is so the lady taken
the picture is so [ __ ] blown away by
how clear the screen is she just keeps
commenting on it and she's not taking
the picture and all the people are
smiling going okay that's great okay and
something goes I can't hold my smile
much longer the other guy goes I can't
always smile either and the robot goes I
can right there you see everything that
just [ __ ] happened in that commercial
they made having a robot seem [ __ ]
normal to the point you're taking a
family [ __ ] photo with it in front of
the Grand Canyon
okay and then the human beings are in
their own way are admitting that they're
not they're not as good as the robot
getting it in your [ __ ] head that
these things are just normal and they
should be in your [ __ ] life and that
you're not worthy you know that [ __ ]
trader from Verizon if you wanted to
redeem himself should have grabbed that
[ __ ] robot and thrown him right off
the class all I'm saying it's how I like
that's how I would have liked it to end
but I know that that's that's in that's
in a perfect world all right LegalZoom
everybody evidently this podcast is
brought to you by legalzoom.com and the
number four you know the saying time is
money it's true especially when you run
your own business but running a
successful business involves taxes
contracts hush money and a whole lot of
fine print things that eat up too much
of your time well it's time to turn to
legal zone over the last 17 years more
than a million Americans have used Legal
Zoom to help launch their business says
business it is but that's only the
beginning Legal Zoom has a network of
independent attorneys these guys went
rogue man they're independent and tax
professionals who can provide you with
advice you need to get through the daily
grind of running your own business and
the best part is you don't have to worry
about driving to anyone's office or
being billed by the hour since Legal
Zoom isn't a law firm I don't care now
they're not a law for me you can take
[ __ ] legal advice from you can't
count on legal you can count on Legal
Zoom to provide the business resources
you need and services that fits into
your schedule invest your time and money
into growing your business and let
LegalZoom help with the legal stuff go
to legalzoom.com now and use the code ba
bu are our I yell ice cream when they
it's all in capitals I yell it Bert
check out for special savings once again
that's promo code at legalzoom.com Legal
Zoom where life meets legal you know
they were proud of that saying where
life meets legal I like it alliteration
its quick its succinct
it's the synced it's succulent
anyways so I don't know what to name
this podcast but I you know Billy it
didn't have his cranberry juice did he
huh well Billy's been on the rag hear
about all the sports I just want a
little bit of Defense that's all bill
for [ __ ] sakes
okay it's over okay no more defense you
can't take your dick out at work and I
don't know what else and it's called
climate change I get it things are
changing I'm getting older things are
changing anyway so I'm having some
people over I invited all these [ __ ]
people to come over my house not
realizing that the OSU [ __ ] Michigan
game is starts at 9:00 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time so kind of changes the
menu I guess I'll be making some
breakfast burritos over there Jesus
Christ I hope [ __ ] Michigan wins it
this year they said it has to become a
rivalry again and wonder what they are
all time I think Michigan had them and
then and now they just did the Ohio
State has gone on such a run I would say
that they caught up and passed them OSU
come on you can't
OSU verse Michigan's anybody watching
that kid down there at Duke Jesus Christ
that man child OSU first Michigan record
here we go maybe that's the one all-time
Michigan football rivalry dude dude all
right let's see early years the snow
bowl and Woody Hayes gotta know
something crazy happen any time I think
I'm angry I just watched Woody Hayes
highlights I'm like a you know I'm not
that bad I hate that [ __ ] bad 10-year
war Hayes verse Shem Bo Schembechler
yeah until Woody Hayes punched that guy
in the [ __ ] under than the jaw member
that the kid intercepted the ball and
what he got so [ __ ] mad was a kid on
the other team he grabbed me punched him
you know the guy wanted to win Michigan
verse OSU all-time head to
year by year maybe this will get it for
me come on man come on man
all-time results here we go yeah that
that that that built that's that's the
notre-dame one I know they also
understand me babe but babe all right
who gives a [ __ ] about weight in 1912
alright let's let's just look over the
last few years all right
Michigan is not won since 2011 all right
OS she was one one two three four five
six years in a row and they've won seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
thirteen of the last fourteen [ __ ]
years Jesus Christ
[Music]
wait a minute in 1998 OS you won't get
the [ __ ] out of here
am i reading these right I'm not reading
this right am I well that's ranking how
[ __ ] difficult can this be oh no no
I'm Reno right okay sorry Jesus Christ
you guys still listening to this I don't
know why people listen to this [ __ ]
podcast this has got to be the most
unprofessional thing ever and I thought
I went in 1999 I went to Ohio State vs
Michigan but Tom Brady played that game
so I wasn't I went to the one in 1998
was it ninety-seven cuz Michigan won the
year I went that I go in 19 I went in 97
I don't [ __ ] remember
alright the 1990s Michigan Michigan was
a tie Michigan Ohio State Michigan
Michigan Michigan OSU Michigan decade
before 80s starting to 1980 when
Michigan Ohio State Ohio State Michigan
Ohio
they Michigan Michigan Ohio State
Michigan Michigan let's see the 70s the
10-year war how state Michigan Ohio
State tie a house state Ohio State
Michigan Michigan Michigan Ohio State so
wait a second my house state went one
two three four five Michigan one two
three four than the tie all right do
they have the all time so what is the
all time
Michigan dominated the early years
compiling a 12o and to record in a
non-conference matchup Jesus Christ look
how small this [ __ ] print is there's
no [ __ ] way all right now I got to
find this [ __ ] thing this is like to
the point am I forgetting than a
podcasting right now whatever see you
guys you know you [ __ ] millennium she
probably ready looked this up 58 [ __ ]
times and I don't know I don't know how
to figure out oh I took my daughter to
Guitar Center for the first time the one
on Sunset Boulevard the big one that
they they redid it was hilarious so I
took a picture of me my daughter right
you know with the Guitar Center logo
behind us and she was reaching for the
camera but it looked like she was doing
the rock star point right at the camera
and I'm sitting there cheese and smiling
next to her so I look like I'm a fan of
hers it's right now it's my favorite
[ __ ] it's my favorite goddamn picture
that I have over by the way thank you to
everybody that signed up to my for my
patreon page
next week me and Joey roses the teen
idol sensation from the Opie and Anthony
program the late great Opie and Anthony
program will be will be doing a couple
more episodes of uninformed yelling at
each other and all that type of [ __ ] I
got the free time now I'm gonna fly the
helicopter get some [ __ ] video for
you and we have exclusive footage from
my show at Madison Square Garden me
doing the soundcheck saying I was gonna
kill I knew it I know I was gonna kill
one of those nights you just could feel
it and then in the end
Andrew [ __ ] walked all the way around
with me Joe and verse are all saying
good night it follows me all
way through the crowd all the way into
the back greenroom and there was another
big-time comic there that I had no idea
that they were there captured that whole
[ __ ] conversation also that's that's
the direction my patreon page is gonna
go it's gotta be a lot of personal [ __ ]
like that that you know I don't mind
putting out there for a few people try
not to do it for a bunch of [ __ ] you
know I feel like I let you in enough
with the primary alright that's the
[ __ ] podcast enjoy the music and then
there's gonna be another half-hour of
content from a Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
from I don't know earlier this year or
ten years ago whenever the [ __ ] I
started doing these things I'm pulling
for Michigan I respect Ohio State I just
wanted to be a rivalry again you know
I'd like to see Jim Harbaugh you know at
this point I mean ones last time his
wife had a good Christmas I mean come on
the guy's got a win here you know I
would think even even even when they do
win you still got to be like you know
when he's around the house away Jim
Jimmy relax okay just you know it's
breakfast you have some toast
where do I get off calling anybody else
a [ __ ] lunatic oh you know what I
love I went to the heart doctor my heart
looks great so right now my chest pains
I know that's just [ __ ] into Jess
tchen what would you do if I [ __ ]
keeled over right now you know it is I
eat too fast all right now I want all
you guys who aren't doctors out there
right now to then tell me you know the
dangers of [ __ ] that what about this
[ __ ] jerk-off who goes through that
goddamn island in the middle of nowhere
and gets his dumb ass killed he [ __ ]
went there one time he gets shot with a
bunch of [ __ ] arrows and then he
[ __ ] comes back again only somebody
like who's delusional with religion can
be that [ __ ] stupid to go over I mean
what the what the [ __ ] are you doing
Jesus cry love to is everybody assumed
it was a [ __ ] white guy myself
included him I guess this day there you
go that's what the [ __ ] we do hey don't
go over there you could get killed
oh yeah where is it
go check it out I think the dude was
asian-american I hate that he lost his
life but I am psyched that for once
somebody did some dumb white guy's [ __ ]
and it wasn't a dumb white guy all right
dumb white guys finish in November's
straw I was wonder what my neighbors
think when I yell [ __ ] like that I can't
tell if he's if he's gone crazy is his
wife in trouble we don't know oh by the
way a massively positive feedback of Nia
reading the questions so oh my god my
[ __ ] daughter gave me [ __ ] for the
first time ever in front of everybody at
Thanksgiving at the Thanksgiving dinner
table she's sitting there and she was
being all whining everything you know
demanding and all of this stuff they go
good lord I go what do you don't know
they what do you weigh the boss baby and
she looks at me she goes you're on a
boss baby and that the whole table was
it was like when spider goes see I went
you go [ __ ] yourself Tommy everybody
just went like oh and I was looking at
Nia going like did she just say that did
she say you're the boss baby or she just
mumbled something that's I know she can
say boss baby but you mean y'all bought
baby was just like Jesus God and now
we've entered this chapter anyways
alright that that's it everybody I hope
you had a lovely Thanksgiving don't be
afraid to go for a walk man go for a
walk and have some fruit and vegetables
you know if the [ __ ] could do that much
damage this weekend you can still enjoy
yourself but you know P don't be a
[ __ ] jerk all right I don't know what
that meant either have a great weekend
you [ __ ] and I'll check the I'll see
you on Monday
[Music]
help yourself a Happy Thanksgiving
even if you're a vegetarian code just
eat your potatoes stuffing and that's
[ __ ] GU but don't be a douche and say
I can't eat the stuffing cuz it was in
the bird friends we here at the Monday
morning podcast want to extend a very
happy and healthy Thanksgiving wish to
each and every one of you and we would
also like it if you took time to think
of those who are a little less fortunate
that's the only [ __ ] thing I hate
about this holiday right this is such a
great [ __ ] holiday in that there's no
corporate [ __ ] all right they can't
get you you know you can't you don't
have to go out and go buy anybody
anything
everybody just makes something to eat
you go over somebody's house and you
[ __ ] throw down and I don't know how
but for some reason this unbelievable
holiday
has remained like corporate free like
they can't figure out how the [ __ ] to
get you to buy something on a day when
it's all about feeding your [ __ ] face
other than food obviously but you know
what I mean they haven't figured out a
way to be like is this the year you
stick the ring in the yams buy her a car
on Thanksgiving you know God knows it
would be all about the [ __ ] broads
right the [ __ ] are you gonna get hunts
I'm sort of we're gonna get have one of
the one of those one of those buzzer
rings how to make your friends laugh
around the water bubbler
that's stunk that was a bad example you
know why cuz I have no [ __ ] example
because basically when you're a man you
stop getting good gifts past the age of
once you're too old for toys that's it
you get close you get [ __ ] right the
[ __ ] broad sit down hey you want this
shiny thing that car ain't only called
six weeks of your pay really why don't
you take this [ __ ] piece of coal
stick it up your hoo-ha and see what
happens in six weeks if it's shiny stick
it on your finger if it isn't shut it
you're sticking your [ __ ] pie hole
that's what I'm trying to say sorry this
is supposed to be about giving thanks no
so I love this [ __ ] holiday you know
I like to eat hey who doesn't right but
every time they have to still [ __ ]
ruin it one of these these Network
douchebags during the Macy's Day Parade
when they're sitting there with their
network earmuffs and gloves on right
with the [ __ ] McGruff trench coat
they always have to say you know
Thanksgiving exactly I felt half a year
and blah blah blah let's [ __ ] you're
ready to throw down
and then they gotta go at the last
second be like but what about Haiti and
then they get a show a bunch of [ __ ]
earthquake victims are still trapped
under a swing set you know it's like can
you just you can I just have one holiday
off can I do that
so I'm not well all I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna watch the [ __ ] football did
that make sense
um anyways hey am I the only guy who
gets creeped out by that [ __ ]
eight-legged turkey John Madden has
every year did he stop doing that cuz
he's retired now there was always
something a little wrong about that or
maybe there was a little bit of
foreshadowing of what manmade turkeys
are gonna look like in a few years right
I mean they already do that with with
the chickens don't they people like
white meat right so they gave him
[ __ ] steroids and now they can't even
walk cuz their pecks are tipping them
over do you guys see food ink did you
see that oh god this podcast started off
with such promise I don't you know where
I am in it right now um anyway so this
is the Monday morning podcast for Monday
here we go let's get back to some
familiar ground here let's get back to
what I say every week for Monday
November 22nd wait a minute November
22nd this is a important day in the
history of America this is uh what is
this this is the 1963 this is the 47th
anniversary of the whacking of President
John F Kennedy right because he was the
first guy who started printing money
outside the Federal Reserve printed out
some [ __ ] coins and they weren't
having that [ __ ] so they [ __ ] whacked
him in Dallas and then to send a message
to every [ __ ] president who came
after him they put his head on the
[ __ ] silver dollar you know not in
honor of him that's the Federal
Reserve's way it's like when you shoot a
deer and you put its head on the wall
that's what the Federal Reserve does
when you [ __ ] with them they blow your
brains out and then they stick your head
on a coin you know but if you play by
the [ __ ] rules they stick you on some
paper that's how it works that's my
theory and I'm going with that
yeah 47 years ago to this day and they
haven't changed anything in Dealey Plaza
in Dallas if you ever go there and you
want to see the creepiest tourist
attraction of all time they have not
even changed a post-office box you walk
there it's like stepping back in time
you can walk around with audio I know
I've talked about this before but for
for all the mates over there and [ __ ]
England down in Australia where
elsewhere else do I have to give
shoutouts to Ireland Scotland Sweden all
the places I've played over there I was
actually talking to my Booker uh my
booking agent last week I'm putting
together another Europe run for 2011
all right you [ __ ] [ __ ] gonna be
another London Dublin glasgow stockholm
sweden maybe I can do a Scandinavian run
over there
you know how great is my [ __ ] life
alright and for all you European
outcasts down under uh we're also
working on Australia and I know I
promised yours come in there in the fall
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened but
uh what are you gonna do you know if you
guys have plenty to do down there right
ac/dc uh that guy threw the phone at
those people Nicole Kidman and her angry
forehead and justin bieber justin bieber
justin bieber is arguably the biggest
star to come out of australia since uh
since that go through the phone that i
could never remember his [ __ ] name
michael strahan by the way was the
football players trying to remember and
just to be a [ __ ] I said Justin Bieber
was from Australia and if you actually
got upset and started screaming at
whatever the [ __ ] you're listening this
to this podcast on right now and you
actually know where the [ __ ] that
person's from you know what does that
say about you you know I'm sick of time
talking about the Justin Bieber haircut
Mick Jagger had that [ __ ] haircut on
the [ __ ] Ed Sullivan Show
you know back then when he wore ties all
right what the [ __ ] is going on here my
brain right now is thinking about making
up like [ __ ] diff twelve different
categories so I don't have to talk about
the same shits getting a little stale
it's getting a little stale for me um
yeah that's um I wanted to talk about
let's talk about [ __ ] front men in
rock music the best frontman of all time
recently I've gone on this this insane
Rolling Stone old-school kick where I
finally downloaded get your Yaya's out
there live concert from Madison Square
Garden it's [ __ ] unbelievable then I
was on the road when I was in Columbus
and I bought another one just called
ladies and gentlemen the Rolling Stones
and they're playing somewhere in Texas
it's just [ __ ] unreal how
unbelievable those guys are is a live
band and I was watching Mick Jagger
and I started thinking cuz I always left
him out of the equation when I was
thinking you know best frontman of all
time and I might have to give it to him
alright you know I always argue Brady
Peyton Manning I think you know who do
you like better you like Freddie Mercury
or Mick Jagger the Freddie Mercury is
[ __ ] unbelievable as far as how that
dude seriously turned Wembley Stadium
into like a coffeehouse and had like it
just a sing-along just him and the crowd
not even the [ __ ] band he's like
sitting down and chilling out like he
sees like he's in his [ __ ] living
room I think as far as charisma and
power of voice and just the ability to
be five foot one a hundred and two
pounds and strut around the [ __ ]
stage and have everybody captivated I
don't know if you can beat Freddie
Mercury but if anybody can I would i
would put mick jagger right up there go
watch some of his live [ __ ] he sees
[ __ ] ridiculous
what an amazing frontman that guys he
did rip off some [ __ ] i saw him when he
was what is that song the Midnight
Rambler you know you know the whole
breakdown part where he's like well have
you heard about the Boston rap all right
well he dropped to his knees milk in the
moment which anybody who's watched music
knows he stole that from James Brown and
he also was doing some his version his
[ __ ] English version you know of those
those little [ __ ] you know the James
Brown thing will you [ __ ] somehow
your feet aren't moving but they are
moving but you're not taking steps and
you go in side to side he steals a
little bit of that but as far as white
dudes go you know what I mean I thought
those would be my top two and I would
listen to either either side of those
arguments so I'll bring them on I want
to hear what you have to get what you
have to say David Lee Roth you know as
far as like heavy metal goes how do you
find a guy you know Robert Plant
I gotta say Robert Plant you know the
whole thing that knocks him down a
little bit is when he wasn't stealing
lyrics from old blues guys he was
singing about dungeons and dragons
before it came out so his [ __ ] I don't
know if it uh if it holds did this
certain certain bands it's weird like
the music holds up but sometimes the
lyrics like I was listening some old
Metallica the other day and is [ __ ]
awesome as they are some of their old
lyrics really has a Keanu Reeves
you know flavor to it
you know the thing that shouldn't be
whoa well is that seek-and-destroy it's
all destruction it sounds like a
twelve-year-old wrote it am i really
criticizing Metallica on a week when I
should be giving thanks that those guys
[ __ ] blew my eardrums out for 30
[ __ ] years I'm sorry you know what
this is my deal I figured out the other
day I have taken 24 flights 24 different
flights this is the life of a touring
comedian since the beginning of October
I basically let's see I flew from LA to
Boston Boston to Minneapolis Minneapolis
to Chicago Chicago to LA then I flew LA
to Chicago Chicago to Albany drove to
Buffalo and then I went Buffalo Chicago
Chicago LA party lost count how many of
those are LA to st. Louis st. Louis LA
LA to Dallas Dallas to Columbus Columbus
to Dallas Dallas to LA
and what the [ __ ] did I go after that Oh
in between their [ __ ] LA to New York
New York back to LA and then this past
weekend I went [ __ ] LA to Newark New
Jersey drove to Pennsylvania did a
college gig drove back to New York
picked up Joe DeRosa over there drove
down to DC did a gig down there went to
the airport got on a [ __ ] Puddle
Jumper flew to Hartford got in a rental
car drove out to Foxwoods did a gig
there drove from Foxwoods back down a
Newark got on a [ __ ] plane and flew
all the way to LA I've done all of that
since the first weekend in New York and
would you believe it I threw my [ __ ]
back out that's what ends up happening
when you fly on planes and [ __ ] you just
sit in there like you're on [ __ ]
punishment and I [ __ ] up my dough my
back got tight the other day I throw out
my back and it's still [ __ ] up I don't
what the hell to do about it you know
not only do I not know what to do about
my back I don't know what to do about
this podcast right now cuz I don't know
what happened was starting off great I
sang you a little [ __ ] song I put an
echo effect on it um you know what let's
talk let's talk a little [ __ ] NFL
football I didn't watch any NFL football
yesterday because I was traveling I
missed it all I did sit down and I
watched the Patriots the Patriots game
and a lot of people sent me emails and
they were anticipating that I was gonna
trash Peyton Manning all right I think
it's time I have to I have to to to
[ __ ] re-emphasize my mission
statement all right somewhere in all
this [ __ ] defending Tom Brady people
think that I hate Peyton Manning the
same way people really think that I
[ __ ] hate the Jets I'm gonna get to
both of those all right Peyton Manning
the [ __ ] I gave him was how they were
calling him the greatest QB of all time
that's where I give him [ __ ]
I give him [ __ ] about that and I give
him [ __ ] about his performance his
playoff record
that's what I do but I don't think he
sucks as a quarterback I just take
offense when somebody says that he's the
greatest quarterback of all time and
that Tom Brady always takes a [ __ ]
backseat to him that's what I don't like
despite Tom Brady's playoff record Tom
Brady's winning percentage he's right
there with Peyton Manning he does better
in the [ __ ] playoffs and their
head-to-head matchups he's [ __ ]
killing the guy so but I you know I
still understand that Peyton puts up
these monster numbers but how about
every once in a while you have a debate
about Tom Brady and Peyton Manning and
it's sort of like maybe six people like
Peyton seven people like Tom Brady just
you know 5050 maybe tips Tom Brady's way
every [ __ ] once in a while just
doesn't happen so yesterday the Patriots
beat the Colts or hung on to beat the
Colts which is why I'm not gonna talk
[ __ ] all right
unlike these [ __ ] Jets fans who keep
winning in the last second against
[ __ ] you know teams that aren't gonna
make the playoffs you know and then they
start sending me emails like they just
want a playoff game which I really don't
understand which I kind of get because
they don't do well in the playoffs for
my entire life so I guess these are
victories so I guess that's why you talk
[ __ ] I have no [ __ ] idea but you know
Peyton Manning yesterday it's not like
we beat the Colts you know that's not
the [ __ ] Marvin Harris Reggie Wayne
Dallas Clark and all those guys you know
what I mean I know Reggie Wayne play but
come on it's like they're they have a
ton of injuries and that defense sucks
all right
but on the other side of the ball we
have two rookie tight ends that are our
offense seems to be built around and
we're starting like three four rookies
on defense so we're both sort of vod's
weird I think both of those teams and
their records are a testament to how
[ __ ] good both of those quarterbacks
are and certainly with the Patriots what
a great coach Bill Belichick is all
right all you [ __ ] [ __ ] who keep
telling me you know keep thrashing Bill
Belichick
you know these guys
still giving me [ __ ] on the internet
about that Spygate [ __ ] horseshit let
me see if I can put this thing to bed
first of all man genie man genius as the
Jets call them jet fans of course
Sanchez man genius
Richard Todd's the next Joe Namath you
know they do that [ __ ] down there right
[Music]
he coached with the Patriots so
evidently if bill if Bill Belichick was
doing that all the time he built his
[ __ ] resume and he has a job right
now in head coaching because of that
Spygate [ __ ] and then he turns around
and rats out Bill Belichick and then
I've also told all you [ __ ] out there
that Bill Belichick is not the only guy
who does that [ __ ]
they sent out a league-wide memo telling
everyone to stop doing it and if you
don't believe me if you don't believe me
that everybody does it watch when head
coaches talk to each other on the
sidelines on NFL Sunday do you notice
that they put their hands up over their
mouth or they take their their [ __ ]
you know that little yeah that sheet
that they have all their plays on and
they put it up over their [ __ ] mouth
they put their hand up over their mouth
like [ __ ] Joe Pesci and Casino when
they're out there in the parking lot why
do you think that is why do you think
that is all you guys who are trying to
blame that [ __ ] epidemic of a crime
on one guy why do you think they do that
do you think it's because they have bad
breath you [ __ ] morons it's because
not only does everybody do it they're
still doing it you just can't do it from
the sidelines
they got people up in the booth
binoculars they got fun I bet they got
people in the crowd with cameras with
zoom lenses there's millions of dollars
at stake
there's egos at stake all right I just
love how people okay people are gonna do
[ __ ] roids take HGH they're gonna
[ __ ] cheat when when the [ __ ] refs
aren't gonna look but you know they're
not going to still continue to videotape
when that technology exists give me a
[ __ ] break all right and if any of
you [ __ ] out there who always [ __ ] she
says that Bella cheat [ __ ] if you can
explain to me why they're covering up
their [ __ ] their hand over their
mouth that if one of you dumb [ __ ]
tries to tell me that someone on the
other sideline with the naked eye can
look through 22 players and read the
lips of somebody I am gonna find out
where you live through
something something calm and I'm gonna
slap you with this [ __ ] microphone
alright so there you go
I actually I can't believe my says I
actually felt bad for Peyton Manning uh
that game he played a great [ __ ] game
he did all the [ __ ] work okay I can't
talk [ __ ] that game was tied up okay if
it Nevada Terry comes in kicks the
[ __ ] field goal alright
this isn't like last year where he had
all his [ __ ] weapons it was the Joe
Montana moment and the reason why I
trashed him because they were already
handing him the crown as the greatest
quarterback of all [ __ ] time before he
even won his second ring so I felt
vindicated so I actually felt bad for
the guy when he's running off the
[ __ ] field and believe me I couldn't
believe it but I actually did I was like
yeah you know God played a great [ __ ]
game you know he doesn't have any of his
weapons he's still hung in there and you
know and I can't talk [ __ ] about the
Patriots because our defense is is it's
just I mean it's it's aged me thirty
years I just watched the replay of the
game and I'm so [ __ ] glad I wasn't
watching that live we're great first
down and second down but third down
yeesh Jesus Christ it's uh we're still
uh I you know I would say two years away
but because we have Bill Belichick I
would say we're still a year away but I
just don't see us going deep into the
playoffs with that [ __ ] defense and
and I still don't think we match up well
against the Jets because they have a
they have a really really good defense
so I think that can neutralize our
offense and then they go out there they
have a great offensive line and uh
Sanchez has too much [ __ ] time I
don't know I but III don't I don't see
them kicking the [ __ ] out of us I mean
we could obviously still win that game
in New England but which I actually have
a feeling we're going to because that's
just how things kind of seem to work out
in the NFL but like you know I don't
know like I honestly I honestly can't
talk [ __ ] about that game it was a
[ __ ] awesome game and I gotta admit
it was a little sad watching Brady and
Peyton Manning with with teams that
weren't as good is back in the [ __ ]
day you know but I I'm hoping that
they're both coming around because it's
a [ __ ] great matchup there you go
look at that look at me the week of
Thanksgiving not being a [ __ ] and let's
see here by some reason I have the Jets
down here the Jets somebody said bill in
two weeks we beat
oh okay here we go it says bill in two
weeks we beat two of the best NFL teams
the Steelers and the Colts see that's
nothing odd the Colts aren't one of the
best teams they they have one of the
best quarterbacks and you're thinking
about Colts teams of the past you can't
see them what say they're one of the
best teams when all their guys are hurt
you know but anyways he says I think
that is nothing compared to the but
however I think that's nothing compared
to the accomplishments of the New York
Jets I praise Rex Ryan Mark Sanchez in
the whole jet organization for
continuing to barely be able to beat
under five hundred teams I mean the
Lions the Browns and now the Texans why
even wait might as well build the Mark
Sanchez statue right now [ __ ] the Jets
[Laughter]
yeah then there's another we I can't
talk [ __ ] cuz the Browns raped us so
this is the thing I've been breaking the
Jets balls about winning last second
every [ __ ] week but you know once you
do it six weeks in a row I mean you
can't ignore that that does say
something about your [ __ ] team so
then after last week when I went one in
three with my gambling you know and I
couldn't pick a [ __ ] winner
I got to admit man this this year has
been really it's kind of [ __ ] awesome
but it's really hard as a gambler trying
to pick you know
like what team is just gonna step out
and just be the [ __ ] team
you know I mean jet fans for as much as
you guys keep winning I mean how much
you agent down there in [ __ ] New
Jersey with the Jersey jets there huh
[ __ ] got to be brutal for you every
week but this week I actually I've gone
two and one and I have to bring this up
here
Paul virzi and I want you guys to give
him [ __ ] too on his Facebook page don't
be overly mean just actually you know
what you would really be funny if you
guys all just sent him letters of
condolences and you just hope that he's
doing alright and if he needs anything
you're there for him just just go with
that angle because he did the
unthinkable the unprecedented last week
okay we picked four games each week
against the spread and against I don't
know how many odds I know how many odds
were stacked up against this man but
Paul virzi
when oh and for last week he [ __ ]
would have been better off if you
blindfolded him spun him around three
times and gave my hand full of darts and
there was teams written on the wall and
just said start throwing I broke his
balls a little bit I was like Jesus
Christ I didn't think Nia could do that
oh so if you have time go to Paul virzi
on Facebook vir Zi don't be a [ __ ] cuz
it's the week of Thanksgiving just just
send him letters of condolences just act
treat him as though a family member just
passed you know or maybe like a family
pet you know not a young family member
like you know somebody like I like a
grandfather that lived you know was 97
and died you know those weird things
where it's like you know you guys how
I'm so sorry for your loss but you know
the [ __ ] he lived to be 97 the lucky son
of a [ __ ]
Oh in [ __ ] four I mean I almost did
it last week one and three but that's
the thing about going on four I mean
it's it's like going Owen 16 in the NFL
somebody it's somebody is gonna come
around and do you a favor right so
tonight the last game I have this is
just like that Seahawks game last week
when I picked Arizona and the second I
picked Arizona I'm like now dude pick
the Seahawks and I was like now stick
with your first choice for some stupid
[ __ ] reason I took Denver and the
points tonight and I just really can see
Phillip Rivers coming out there with a
[ __ ] vengeance
you know
have a shout-out to one of my listeners
who I didn't see the email but he gave
me five picks for this week and he went
for and one against the spread so hats
off to you sir you are a you're a better
man than me all right let's move on here
let's get on with the oh my drinking
people are asking me about my drinking
or the lack thereof uh yes this is my
37th day of sobriety I got this [ __ ]
down I got it down I'm gonna I'm easily
gonna make it to the Rose Bowl because
I've already I've already gone through
my tough drinking towns I went to DC I
went through New York I worked with Joe
DeRosa Chicago Minneapolis what the [ __ ]
else are you gonna do up there oh by the
way I saw I saw that show man vs. food
and that was a show that I used to make
fun of I thought it was [ __ ] stupid
and it's just like a this is dumb I
don't know watch this [ __ ] sweaty guy
eat all this goddamn food I don't what
happen I was on the road and I watched
him I don't know where he was but he
[ __ ]
he ate this sandwich was a hit eat a
turkey sandwich that I swear to God was
the size of a purse who stacked that
[ __ ] high it was ridiculous and then
it came with a shake that you could
literally put you could like you know
people who like have like like a tree
growing in their house you know big that
[ __ ] pot is that that that was all
[ __ ] was 4 pounds of milkshake so the
dude eats all but two bites of the
turkey sandwich
he sucks down this shake that looked
like you [ __ ] was it as big as a fire
hydrant worth the [ __ ] milkshake he
sucks this whole [ __ ] thing down he's
got 20 minutes to go to eat the final
two [ __ ] bites and he's just sitting
there with like he you know like the
thinker you know that pose that great
statue he's sitting there like that
except he's sweating and it took him 17
minutes to eat two bites I mean I could
have stuck both bites in my mouth and
ate him in like 30 seconds that's how
[ __ ] full this guy was and how hard
he had to concentrate to not just
[ __ ] blow chow
right after he [ __ ] a bloke ow Jesus
Christ that's from my high school days
did you hear about Eddie yeah he's
drinking he [ __ ] blew Chow last night
kid trying not to [ __ ] puke but
anyways he went to he went to
Minneapolis and he there was some sort
of sandwich up there that two places
claimed
what the [ __ ] was the sandwich two
places claim that they are the original
could somebody please tell me what that
place is what the name of that place is
I want to [ __ ] go there because I
want to try that sandwich cuz it looked
delicious
and for that matter if you see a city
that I'm going to if I'm coming to your
city and there's that [ __ ] place
where you gotta go like when I went to
Buffalo and they had anchor bar and I
was at Duffy's or something like that
like those are the two places to get you
know they basically invented buffalo
wings if you know of any of those places
please let me know because I'm really
running out of [ __ ] sporting events
to go to you know unless I want to start
to go into like you know Little League
games and stand there like a [ __ ]
pervert I'll just show up with those
black frame glasses standing you know
close enough to the field but just far
enough away from the rest of the crowd
you know all by myself just looking like
a [ __ ] creep please let me know those
because I got to tell you you know I'm
having a [ __ ] I'm having more goddamn
fun on the road right now I'm just
meeting a lot of you know I'm finally
getting to do some theatres I'm having
great shows you know I feel like I got
my new hour it's starting to get solid
and I don't know I'm not boozing so I'm
kind of doing other [ __ ] checking out
some restaurants and whatnot so if you
know of the some of those places please
let me know all right and with that
let's get on with the drinking question
hey Bill so now that you have 30 plus
days 37 30 plus days without any booze
in you what are the pros and cons I
remember when you were gone when you
were on the wagon earlier this year you
said something to the effect of it being
a little boring and you remembered every
second of every day I'm really
interested to hear what the pros are in
your opinion do you feel more energetic
clear-minded etc by the way are you a
little squeamish too about Frankenstein
man what Frankenstein Manning is gonna
do to the Pats secondary tomorrow go
Pat's
yeah see ya true patriot fans were
[ __ ] nervous yeah I was I was nervous
the only thing I was counting on was the
fact that he wasn't coming in with the
cult team that you were used to but
anyways back to the drinking questions
what are the pros and cons
all right let's go with the cons first
because those are funnier the cons are
you know what the hardest part about not
drinking is is you you you'll never
realize how much you are bombarded with
beer commercials until you stop drinking
and it's not the dumb beer commercials
you know the ones like the corona ones
where it's the battle of the sexes or
those ones where they you know they're
just trying to be funny where they're
just like yeah you know why don't you
order a real beer well you know when you
take your skirt off or whatever you know
those are just silly are those [ __ ]
Budweiser frogs and lizards back in the
day those ones don't make you want to
drink but those ones where they talk
about the clean refreshing you know and
they don't you know without those
[ __ ] Sam Adams commercials with a guy
with the beard is burying his face in to
all those hops and then they just did
just pour in the [ __ ] beer into that
perfect beer glass those are the ones
where I start [ __ ] you know I start
getting all clammy like you know
and it's weird when you're not drinking
because if I'm drinking and I see one of
those I'll just I'll either not even
notice it or I'll just be like damn I
want a beer and I'll go get one but when
I'm going cold turkey when I see those
commercials I'm like god damn I would
like about 56 of those right about now I
would like to man versus booze oh [ __ ]
there's a youtube video don't do it I
don't condone it but if you do it I'm
gonna watch it the health risks are
unbelievably dangerous do not do that do
not let's you can't do man vs. booze
somebody's gonna [ __ ] die which is
why they don't have any of those
challenges in a bar so strike all of
that do not do that but that's what
those beer commercials make me want to
do man vs. booze and it makes me want to
sit there and oh god how about a fun
challenge that would be can you imagine
if you had like you know you like those
uh how much I want to drink right now
you know you know those uh you know
those those refrigerators that you that
people keep wine bottles in wine 1 1 of
wine fridges refrigerator wine things so
[ __ ] stupid whatever the [ __ ] you call
those things you know with had the glass
door so you can see you can see the
bottles chilling in there imagine if you
had a [ __ ] ceiling to floor
just like refrigerator had a glass door
and behind it you just saw a bunch of
frosty [ __ ] bottles of beer you know
and on the other one was just a bunch of
frosty [ __ ] awesome looking beer
glasses right and you had you had to
kill them all
even if you couldn't [ __ ] do it the
amount of goddamn fun that would be
see this is why I'm never gonna make it
I'm not gonna go my whole life
because you know I think I might do that
with DeRosa when I eventually get off
the wagon we might do man vs. booze
what is wrong with me see this this is
the cons of going just totally cold
turkey is you start having fantasies
like I just got lost in that Jesus
Christ and then I was thinking like yeah
we'll do it we'll [ __ ] take a
vacation we'll have a [ __ ] house on
the lake like this whole homoerotic
[ __ ] beer fantasy with Joe DeRosa the
[ __ ] is wrong with me that's what I was
literally thinking you know cuz when you
do something like that you want to make
sure you got no place else to go okay
that's one of the cons you start
fantasizing about booze so much you
actually put yourself in so semi gay
situation with one of your best friends
ah god damn it one of the things I love
most about Joe DeRosa he's a complete
[ __ ] that's what I love about it you
know there's nothing better than hanging
out with a [ __ ] it's because you know
it's just no pressure
for you to get your [ __ ] together it's
like when you hang out with a do-gooder
it's a constant reminder of how awful
you are as a person and how shitty
you're living your life but when you get
hang out with a guy like Joe DeRosa you
know he's smart about it he gets his
work done
he finishes writing the script he does
his shows but afterwards he's old-school
he really is he's like Dean Martin
without the charisma and the good looks
um anyways why am i trash and Joe on
Thanksgiving huh it's a week to give
thanks I give thanks to that you know
that Joe DeRosa and for years US
comedians have always trashed Joseph Joe
DeRosa talking about how he doesn't have
any shoulders and I have maintained for
a good two and a half years I've been
screaming I've been telling two to two
people with definite yelling at deaf
ears what's that [ __ ] expression
whatever I'm talking to people or not
listen to me Joe DeRosa does not lack
shoulders he has shoulders but what he
doesn't have is that those two chunks of
flesh you know the chunk of flesh on
either side of your neck uh yeah between
your neck and your shoulder that bet
meat right there the trap easy muscle is
that what it is he doesn't have that he
doesn't have collarbones
that's what happened his collarbones
never grew while the rest of his
skeletal system grew his collarbones
didn't so hence there was no need to put
flesh in there so Joe is a head
he's a neck and on either side of his
neck he had this ball and socket joints
for his shoulders are right where those
those rivets were on the side of
Frankenstein's necks neck next pleural
idiot all right let's plow ahead here 36
minutes in so those are the cons as you
start fantasizing about booze and for me
anyways I can't speak of for anybody
else but it just makes you want to drink
like 90 [ __ ] beers like that there's
a bar there's a German bar on the Upper
East Side and this time went out when I
go off the wagon this is where I want to
go they have this insane I can't
remember if it's a boot or if it's one
of those things those beer glasses that
looks like a giant [ __ ] bong you know
like that's what I want to drink I want
to drink one of those or just one of
those giant mugs of [ __ ] beer that's
the con right now because as great as I
feel that's what I think of in my head
when I think about drinking every day
the glass gets bigger
frosty err and uh Jesus I'm gonna start
drinking halfway through this podcast if
I keep talking about it all right
what are the pros weight loss
specifically in your face it if your
face tightens up it's great you get your
jawline back when some drunk [ __ ] comes
up to you with [ __ ] cigarettes and
wine breath you see her for what she is
all right you don't hang out with people
after the show they get all drunk and
[ __ ] loud and what you end up do
you're standing there and what you
really start hearing is these cliched
conversations that you have participated
in for the last 25 [ __ ] years of your
life you know you stand back and you get
to watch people slowly lose control of
their
their judgment and you start to see
people say things and do things that
they're gonna apologize or regret for
regret for or regret the next day
[Music]
what else it starts to make you look at
where you are in your life you know and
I don't know if you're gonna do
something that's sort of scummy you have
to do it stone sober and I think a lot
of times when I do dirtbags [ __ ] you
know or I just do dumb [ __ ] I I think
it's because I'm drunk and I think
that's why I'm drinking
just cuz I'm shouting down that voice in
my head that's telling me bill go to bed
right now just go to bed read you know
finish that script that's another thing
too was I start drinking when I start
thinking of the sketch I was gonna write
or something like that I haven't done it
and I'm like I'm gonna do it tomorrow
and I start thinking you know the
successful guys would be it going back
to the hotel room right now and they'd
be finishing it right take out a little
[ __ ] feather you know stick it in
that inkwell and they they would finish
writing it out but not you here you are
you sitting here talking to these
[ __ ] people about football from the
1970s so um there's plenty of prose
about it you know I think if you're in a
[ __ ] up relationship and you sober up
that'll help you you know I think I
think a lot of people kind of use booze
as a way to sort of medicate their way
through the year you know and not
address [ __ ] that's really pissing them
off and stuff I don't know I don't know
it makes you want to work out it makes
you want to change other stuff in your
life where and actually go out and do
things it's another thing to see now I'm
talking about going to cities I want to
go to cool places to eat and that type
of stuff and rather than you know where
are the bars at so I can do what I've
already done for the last 25 [ __ ]
years so there you go those are the pros
I'm not saying you gotta quit for good
unless you're a full-on alcoholic
obviously I would quit it for good but
if
you know if you're just getting that big
Ted Kennedy head it's great to take a
[ __ ] month off you know I don't
that's it I don't about you guys but
I've just been boring the living [ __ ]
out of myself this week all right let's
get to underrated overrated all right
this is this is gonna cause some [ __ ]
emails all right
overrated reverse racism I love how
white men tell minorities to quit
whining about how unfair things are but
the second they become victims of racism
all you hear is I can't insert complaint
because I'm white take some of your own
advice
take some of your own advice you [ __ ]
hypocrite could I have butchered that
anymore let me go back and read that
reverse racism
I love how white men tell minorities to
quit whining about how unfair things are
but the second they become victims of
racism all you hear is I can't insert
complain because I'm white take some of
your own advice you [ __ ] hypocrite
there's the read I [ __ ] love that one
I 100% agree with that one it's
embarrassing when I hear white guys
specifically white guys you know white
women still complained cuz that's what
women do of all colors they just [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ] about
something you know take them to the
restaurant that they've always wanted to
go to you take them there and what
happens right [ __ ] about the table it's
cold I like it but it's cold do you have
the [ __ ] blah blah blah do you have
that special they take it off the menu
that and then they pout and what do you
want to do you want to [ __ ] take the
check when it comes and stuff it down
the back of their throat like that
creepy moth that Hannibal Lecter's or
that or that one [ __ ] dude used to do
in that movie that I can't remember the
name of Jason's crisis podcast sucks
yeah I really I you know I really can't
like listening to white people [ __ ]
about white guys [ __ ] about you know
like affirmative action when they [ __ ]
about that type of [ __ ] all I can say is
if you can't keep your [ __ ] head
above the line you know come on really
you fault you know do you know a bunch
you have to be [ __ ] up as a white
dude to get under that [ __ ] line like
say colleges when they have that
affirmative action thing so then
somebody gets the same scores of you but
they're not white so they [ __ ] get in
and you're gonna sit there and [ __ ]
moan and come on seriously come on you
got enough [ __ ] advantages
you [ __ ] up on you gotta take that one
on the chin that's how I view it and so
I'm gonna support that one because I
know it's also gonna bring a bunch of
[ __ ] emails we could talk about race
on the podcast something I would love to
do alright underrated Michael Vick love
him or hate him he's the best QB in the
league right now you see that right
there there you go
this is what this is that is the ESPN
way of looking at football did you watch
Michael Vick last week against the
hapless [ __ ] Washington Redskins and
they're awful defense you would have
thought Jesus Christ himself was playing
[ __ ] quarterback they would you they
couldn't they said this is one of the
most of making game day if every gig
Michael Vick is getting Michael bit and
Michael Vick taint one [ __ ] game in
the middle of November and this guy is
suddenly he suddenly catapults [ __ ]
Tom Brady Peyton Manning it is as far as
like all their accomplishments all the
things that they've done
he cares like two to two or three good
[ __ ] games and right now he is the
best QB in the [ __ ] league jesus
[ __ ] christ
that's just it just [ __ ] unreal I get
it he's the fastest [ __ ] guy in the
NFL you can't [ __ ] tackle the guy I
get it he's staying in the pocket now
and he's actually doing what a
quarterback is supposed to be doing you
know when the first guy isn't open he
doesn't take off and run anymore he
looks for the second a third third guy
open I get that [ __ ] all right and I'm
not saying like somebody asked me last
week when he was doing what he did
against the Redskins he said do you
think this makes Michael Vick the best
quarterback in the league I said look if
he does what he did tonight against the
[ __ ] Redskins like three weeks in a
row
he becomes without a doubt
shoulder-to-shoulder with the best
cubies in the [ __ ] league okay but
you got to win in January you got to
lead your team in the [ __ ] playoffs
almost it doesn't mean she I mean yeah
it's amazing the guy's [ __ ] he's most
athletic dude I have ever seen he's got
an unbelievable army flit he has all the
fatigue that he has all the [ __ ]
tools to become the greatest [ __ ] QB
of all time if he actually starts to
play the position where he stays in the
pocket and does that without a [ __ ]
doubt but no he's not the best QB in the
[ __ ] league right now
he's not he's the most [ __ ] amazing
to watch I don't this dis is good this
gets back to me when people think I hate
the [ __ ] Jets this is what I hate I
hate people who get crowned King before
they take the [ __ ] crown that's what
I can't stand that's why I went off on
Payton last week that's why I'm going
off on the Jets this year you guys
listened his podcast for three [ __ ]
years I've made fun of the Jets in that
type of [ __ ] but it hasn't been like
this year and the reason was was because
that hard-knock [ __ ] talking that they
did was the most over-the-top
disrespectful [ __ ] thing I've seen in
so god they're in [ __ ] Rex Ryan yeah
we'll go undefeated in September we're
gonna kick the [ __ ] out of then we'll
kick the [ __ ] out of those [ __ ] days
[ __ ] guy and everybody's talking
about how confident the guy was and I
called him out on it and you know what I
was [ __ ] right I was right they
weren't that [ __ ] good and they still
aren't that [ __ ] good they are
winning games at the last second they
lost their first [ __ ] game they lost
to the Ravens and they lost to the
Packers they've yet to play the Colts
which are they're not really that good
this year but they haven't played the
[ __ ] Steelers they haven't blown
anybody away other than the [ __ ]
Patriots with their awful [ __ ]
defense so where do you get off talking
all this [ __ ] that's why I'm giving them
[ __ ] okay I really don't give a [ __ ] you
know I give a [ __ ] this year if they win
the Superbowl but I don't get I don't
wish that [ __ ] misery on Jets fan do
you really think I want you guys to go
your whole lifetime and never win a
championship I don't I don't all right
but this year I don't want you to
because you talked all that you guys
didn't talk all that [ __ ] because Rex
Ryan talked all that [ __ ] that's all
this [ __ ] is about all right but other
than that I don't give a [ __ ]
it's fun that they're good it's not fun
when they suck that game against the
Colts yesterday wasn't fun because
what's this cuz Peyton Manning didn't
have all his guys it's not you know what
I mean
it'd be like beating the Yankees if
while Jesus their whole [ __ ] team
would have to go down the amount of
[ __ ] free agents they sign
it'd be like beating I don't know I
don't what the [ __ ] you you know what
the [ __ ] I'm saying alright so don't get
like this whole thing you know switch I
know I say over-the-top [ __ ] but I'm
just trying to be funny here right so
you [ __ ] who are taking this [ __ ] way
too [ __ ] seriously speaking of which
I got some audio for you guys that uh
one of my great listeners sent in to me
and I absolutely love this [ __ ] audio
but it's also embarrassing to me because
this guy reminds me I hate how much I am
just like this guy I hate that I give a
[ __ ] about sports as much as this guy
speaking of the Eagles and the Redskins
okay for my friends overseas either way
the there was a football game Eagles
played the Redskins and the Eagles
[ __ ] rape the Redskins so this this
radio host goes on the radio and has a
12-minute [ __ ] meltdown
all this [ __ ] he's had to endure as a
Redskins fan which is kind of funny
because they've won three Super Bowls in
my lifetime so I part of it is hilarious
cuz he goes you know it's been 10 years
of this [ __ ] and I just would love to
see him do that rant and get to that
that moment and say it's been 10 years
of this [ __ ] and say that standing on in
in the middle of Wrigley Field when it's
packed it's been 10 years of this [ __ ]
oh you poor [ __ ] baby but it's
actually to be honest it's been longer
than that cuz you know it's good going
on like 20 years and what's way you get
you can start getting up around 20 years
it sucks as a fan just talk to the
Canadian fans up there you know it's
starting to suck up there isn't it
you guys got to be you guys got to be
happy the Canadians look really good
this year they have a really solid
[ __ ] team but the fact that the
Canadians haven't wanted since 1993 so
unbelievable that franchises they've
never gone this long in the history of
that of that franchise they've never
gone anywhere near this long without
winning a Stanley Cup those [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think right up until
1979 I think they had a better winning
percentage Dan I think the Yankees
I might be wrong on that no I think I'm
I might I think I'm right on that I
think they were average in winning one
every [ __ ] three one every three
years easily I the [ __ ] knows I'm bad at
math but anyways so anyways just go to
the mmm podcast calm this [ __ ] rant
is so funny and and first of all
somebody sent the email and told me that
this guy was gonna go off and what makes
it so goddamn funny is the way he starts
the rant I thought it was just gonna be
some guy blowing a gasket but it starts
the he starts it so calmly he just
starts off saying something to the
effect of you know
my grandfather was a Redskins fan
he used to watch Sammy baa then he goes
to his death
he literally did background my dad was a
Redskins fan I've been a [ __ ] fans I
probably spent in my lifetime probably I
don't know seven eight thousand dollars
on throwback jerseys and Redskins
merchandise he lays the [ __ ]
groundwork he gives you the [ __ ]
backstory
and then he just launches into this
thing and I got a MIT man I got 10
minutes into it I just shut it off
because I was so embarrassed that I have
I've blown a gasket like this guy I mean
he gets like 7 minutes into it and I'm
like talking to the guy like dude it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter this
much just let it go and it's actually
really funny except for this this guy in
the background keeps going kid him kid
get him and it really gets [ __ ]
annoying other than that is [ __ ]
hilarious
all right 52 minutes in let's let's move
on here all right this this [ __ ]
segment is really taken off I'm loving
this one
this segment is best line in a bad movie
uh and this week's video which is up on
the mmm podcast calm you got to watch
this one please do not have any food in
your mouth when you watch this because
you will spit it all over a loved one
watch the video Steven Seagal blood bank
it's just [ __ ] awesome I really want
to just go out one night and just rent
five of the worst [ __ ] movies ever
and just sit there and watch it with a
couple of people that can appreciate it
because some of the lines and these
[ __ ] movies are incredible please
please keep sending me these videos
because it's just making a nice long
list of movies that I have to sit down
and watch you know is great for that by
the way too you guys fans a 30 rock and
I'm only gonna name a name here because
this is something positive Judah
Friedlander is an encyclopedia
of knowledge on movies in general but
forget about bad movies and if I
remember correctly he actually collects
them and I have to you know what I gotta
get I'm gonna have him as a guest on
this show and before he comes on I'm
gonna I'm gonna ask for his top five
worst movies best worst movies of all
time and I'm telling you he can break
these movies down like Siskel and Ebert
back in the [ __ ] day as to why they're
great not why not only they're awful but
they're also great like he saw this is
what I'm one of the many things I miss
about living in New York was running
into him and I would always bring up you
know it all started one time I was I was
hanging out at the Comedy Cellar and he
was down there and I was trying to
remember this name of this Steven Seagal
movie and I was like I was like dude
what was the name of that movie Steven
Seagal had is one of his earlier ones
and he fought all those those [ __ ]
Bob Marley looking dudes and he just
goes without even missing a beat he just
goes marked for death great movie
and I go what was the plot of that he
goes the plot of that movie is basically
Steven Seagal beats up Jamaica I'm
butchering all this [ __ ] he said in a
much funnier way and then he then he
broke down why that movie was great and
it basically came down to who said that
movie introduced the breaking of bones
in martial art movies according to him
or or took it to just an entirely
different level and I'm telling you if
you watch mark for death in your
squeamish that's not a movie to watch
because I've never seen so many compound
fractures is that the compound fracture
is that the one where where it comes out
through the skin that's the one I'm
talking about all right
once again I start talking and I get in
over my head i suspend the easy
listening podcast all right here we go
YouTube videos for the week I can't
remember if I put this one up last week
but I look up the car James Brolin it's
a one of the worst and hilarious
trailers I've ever seen in my life this
is another movie that I have to see
white line fever is another one those
are two bad movie trailers angry birds
peace treaty and and here's another
segment I'm going to introduce if you
guys have all-time favorite classic
YouTube videos alright look up food
fight
and try to guess which Wars that they're
talking about I'm a [ __ ] the first time
I watched it and just thought it was
funny because it was food blowing each
other up and then I really started to
see the the metaphors or was it the
similes
I never simile is using like her abs
well then they would have to say America
is a cheeseburger that's a metaphor
assembly would be America is like a
cheeseburger alright you'll understand
it when you watch the video if you
haven't seen it yet and as far as
drummers goes this week this is another
Stewart Copeland one and this is a band
that I meant to get into and I don't
know what happened I got so busy but uh
moister head watch the YouTube video oz
is ever floating as a performance that
they did live on Conan O'Brien and the
ban was Stewart Copeland on drums
what's-his-face I just went I just
spaced on his [ __ ] name
tray
the guy from fish
I forget his [ __ ] name Anastasia oh I
was never a big fish fan I think they're
awesome but I just can't listen to
[ __ ] 58 minutes songs and on bass was
Les Claypool that was the band and
they're [ __ ] awesome and I'm gonna
download some of this [ __ ] alright and
with that I think I don't think we have
left I'm gonna end with advice which
really seems to be the way that we end
do I have time for a couple quick
questions I don't think I do alright
let's get to the advice for the week
alright question bill being a frequent
flyer don't you think this controversy
over the new body scanners is [ __ ]
[ __ ] a guy hit a bomb in his [ __ ]
underwear what exactly do these
complaining bastards expect us to scale
back on security we have become so
pampered and used to the utmost comfort
that we are doing the terrorist job for
them who gives a [ __ ] if someone is
seeing your [ __ ] or your tits he or she
is seeing hundreds a day you sir are a
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright if you go through
airport security I don't know if you've
noticed they're not exactly the [ __ ]
Navy SEALs although they have gotten
better in the last couple of years but
they don't you know they're always
shooting the [ __ ] they're always [ __ ]
around they're not really paying
attention it doesn't really look like
it's a high paying [ __ ] job alright
let's go with that alright let's go as
secondly a body scanner entire body scan
let's get over the fact that you don't
want a naked picture of yourself which
is your [ __ ] right to not want that
by the way alright secondly I don't know
about you but I fly every other weekend
and when I go on benders like this at
the end of the year cuz I owe the banker
[ __ ] and the [ __ ] government a bunch
of money I go on like you know four or
five weeks in row
I fly alright so I got to get a full
bond body scan on the
way out and the way back
you know I really have to start checking
to see that I'm not gonna be completely
filled up with memory on this [ __ ]
Olympus LS ten they have the goddamn
time right there I apologize let me get
back to what the [ __ ] I was talking
about
yeah so so you're basically saying that
I shouldn't complain that like six weeks
in a [ __ ] row and a total of 12 times
I'm gonna take radiation from head to
[ __ ] toe all right and don't even
tell me oh it's only for a [ __ ]
second do when you go to get your
[ __ ] you know teeth x-rayed
they put that leather [ __ ] that lead
vest leather that led vest over all your
[ __ ] organs and then they go they
leave the [ __ ] room and I'm supposed
to stand there like I'm at a jay-z
concert and I'm getting frisked at the
same time with my [ __ ] legs spread
and doing that jay-z thing over my head
and they're gonna know [ __ ] that
this cancer in my family I'm not doing
it I'm not doing it Pat me down so
that's why I did the money on the on the
way out I was like yeah I'm not doing
that thing and I said to Pat me down so
then you know they did it and they said
they came up to me and this guy said I
have to Pat you down are there any parts
of your body that are the artists that
are sensitive and I wanted to be like
well I'm think all of us have areas of
our body that are sensitive just to
creep him out that's basically like now
ed grab my balls I don't give a [ __ ]
right I don't know what he was gonna do
right so he puts on his dishwashing
gloves and starts patting me down and
they don't grab your balls what they do
is they go way up your inner thigh and
he gives you your ball bag a little bit
of a backhand on each side of the ball
bag you know so and I got a mint it made
me laugh a little bit yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] yeah go [ __ ] yourself yeah you're
not taking a [ __ ] head-to-toe naked
[ __ ] picture of me as you you know
you know you're not [ __ ] radiating my
entire body so I can get on a [ __ ]
puddle jumper to go to Hartford I'm not
doing that go [ __ ] yourself
Jesus Christ lazy [ __ ] you know
what people forget is oh I don't get it
you know I understand that they're you
know quote-unquote trying to keep me
safe but what I don't understand is that
people don't understand that during
those times of fear and let's try to
keep you safe the amount of [ __ ] like
privilege that you lose and you never
[ __ ] get it back and they always take
a little more than they should
that's why it's great that people [ __ ]
and it's great that you can [ __ ]
because if you [ __ ] like this in China
they probably put you to death and then
harvest your [ __ ] organs all right so
yeah I think it's fine with the amount
of [ __ ] cancer that's out there and
that people [ __ ] talk on their cell
phones all the goddamn time you don't
want to end it you know you don't want
to add to it with head to toe [ __ ]
zapped a [ __ ] radiation
you know I'm standing there I don't have
my [ __ ] shoes on
I'm stripped down to a [ __ ] t-shirt I
got jeans on it [ __ ] I don't have
anything on me
you know and there's all these [ __ ]
flipping out about the [ __ ] airplanes
what about trains
you could literally have a box that said
I have dynamite on the side of it and
you could keep the [ __ ] conductor
would help you carry it on there's no
metal detectors there's no nothing
despite the fact that 15 years ago that
guy got on the Long Island rady Railroad
and shot that shut the whole [ __ ]
thing up so I don't like that I don't
like that whole [ __ ] I scan scan my
retinas [ __ ] no go [ __ ] yourself I'm not
doing that and it's you're right dude if
you have no problem with it
you know good luck with your testicular
slash brain slash tongue slash throat
slash big toe cancer if you fly all the
[ __ ] time like a lot of people I'm
not doing that [ __ ] I'm not [ __ ]
doing that that's
they have [ __ ] debt you know and you're
acting like before this [ __ ] went down
they haven't been keeping us safe
you know
they have been since 911 knock on wood
nothing has [ __ ] happened before
those stupid body scanners nothing has
[ __ ] happened all right
we're fine everything is [ __ ] fine
you don't need those goddamn things you
know it's funny
as if next week somebody actually does
something the conspiracy theorists are
gonna say that the government did it
because people were refusing those body
scanners all right that's just my
opinion man I seriously you know I'm not
trying to get head to toe radiation I I
get that they're trying to [ __ ] keep
me safe but you know if they truly
wanted to keep me [ __ ] safe they
wouldn't be shooting the [ __ ] and joking
the amount of [ __ ] times that they
are when I'm going through alright and
that happens a lot specifically it's the
person who's looking at the TV screen is
talking about whatever and it's joking
and laughing which you're gonna do
because they have an unbelievably boring
[ __ ] job I would be doing the same
goddamn thing but if they truly gave a
[ __ ]
they would spend a lot more money on the
people that they get to do the security
rather than these newfangled [ __ ]
goddamn machines I'm not going through
those pat me down get my [ __ ] my ball
bag a couple of back hands with your
dishwashing gloves I don't give a [ __ ]
but I'm not gonna stand there spread
eagle and end up with cancer or the
taint all right but you know do you guys
want to do it go ahead and do it I don't
give a [ __ ] but I hope enough of you say
no so it doesn't become mandatory all
right that's it all right let's get with
the advice here all right hey hey the ed
bill I need your thoughts in this
situation this girl I hooked up with was
a freak I never banged her I just
fingered her and got her off and she
blew me her ass was huge it was amazing
she texted she texted me the next day
and saying how amazing it was and how
crazy she got off and loved it I thought
the next date our third was gonna be the
fun sex fest no doubt about it but out
of nowhere she said she didn't want to
do this anymore
she was moving down to Irvine leaving
her old apartment that was just a few
miles from me and she said we wouldn't
ever hang out again so she didn't stay
in touch now the one time she she was
meeting up with friends in Santa Monica
my neck of the woods we texted back and
forth and by the end of the night she
flaked again well wait a minute you said
she's not keeping in touch
I guess when she left she didn't keep in
touch but then she texted you when she
came back to town I'm gonna have to
assume that because I can't talk to you
all right said you're gonna meet at the
end of the night and then she flaked
again she said she liked to rendezvous
but of course she never did then she
asked me why I'm obsessed with seeing
her I told her the truth that I had a
fun time with her and we both had a
blast and she clearly got off and I
figured we could continue this good
thing we got going
I didn't directly say I want to [ __ ] her
but the point probably came across in
the texting I'm straightforward with
women bill I'm also aware of how this
girl's been and he left out a few words
I'm assuming he's saying been messing
with my brain
I even told her I couldn't shake a rough
I felt used but since we didn't [ __ ] it
wasn't a good use the mission wasn't
complete hot sex on a platter makes the
missioning makes the makes the mission
complete Jesus we don't talk anymore I
haven't seen her and I'm bummed I never
banged her I was hoping you might have
some insight as to why she suddenly
stopped seeing me she wasn't faking it
she was really digging me and suddenly
she halted the whole operation before I
could bang her what gives me help me out
please give me some insight all right
dude well I don't know her and I so I
can't really break her down that much
there's a number of reasons why she she
could have done it all right he said the
girl was a freak
look the fact that all she did was bang
you and you're now jonesing for her and
you're saying that she's a freak and
everything and then out of nowhere she
said she didn't want to do this anymore
is one or two things that's either a
one of those those girls who fancies
themselves a femme fatale and they like
getting guys all worked up and then just
dropping you like a [ __ ] hot potato
you know just to [ __ ] with your head
there are girls out there that like
doing that
but if I had to guess because she
actually blew you and did bring you to
orgasm I would say that this sounds like
a bad girl trying to reform herself or
for people who are more liberal this is
a woman who's had her fun and she's
realizing that when she begins a
relationship the way she did with you
that uh that it doesn't go anywhere
but she still loves to [ __ ] and she's
fighting that so she moves away maybe
she bangs so many guys in that area she
needed us she needed a new start so
she's down there and [ __ ] San Diego
wherever the [ __ ] she went and now she's
you know she's being that girl you know
I used to [ __ ] blah blah blah but now
I don't you know maybe she's looking for
a husband so maybe that's why she did it
I have no [ __ ] idea maybe she's
lonely down in San Diego she misses her
friend she comes back and in a moment of
weakness she texts you and then she
starts crying to her friends going look
at I'm gonna hook up with this guy I
don't even like him and I just like
going soothe and don't do it you don't
have to do this you're doing so good
right now you're not being a [ __ ] then
then she leaves you hanging but I'll
tell you this right now you got to let
her go
you got to let her go all right
be like when it comes to women if you're
just out there and you want to [ __ ] you
got to be like a relief pitcher all
right if you serve up a [ __ ] meatball
and they knock it out of the park you
can't be throwing your next pitch
thinking about the last one you got to
let the [ __ ] go start over again so
right now what you need to do is go out
and find another [ __ ] freakin witch
you know if you're straightforward with
women like you are you're gonna find one
and if you really just take the time to
try to break them down and see what
different kinds of women respond to you
literally become like a fisherman and
you know whatever kind of woman you're
looking for that's the bait you toss it
out there all right if you're looking
for a wife or a serious girlfriend you
don't go to a meat market you know join
a softball league take a cooking class
or something like that go where the good
girls are you know or if you do go out
to the meat market look at the one who's
actually watching her alcohol intake the
one who seems to be the responsible one
responsible a wife a mother to your
children right when it doesn't have her
stuff all hanging out
but you know if you're looking for who
with you know
there's all kinds of places to go
actually the great thing about [ __ ] is
they're everywhere that's what I love
about him you know it's like bottled
water you pretty much get it wherever
you go no you know what I mean you got
the office [ __ ] you got the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] at the gym you know the one who
shows up in full makeup and [ __ ] you
know works out on level one on the
Stairmaster looking over his shoulder to
see who's checking her out right that
girl's a [ __ ] nightmare
even if she blows you're gonna have
makeup all over your lap here's the
funny I finally got to the funny a
[ __ ] hour in ten minutes into the
goddamn podcast where was it all week
you know what the reason why this
podcast wasn't as funny as usual is
because you know I was thinking about
all the people who don't get to laugh in
the world this week you know this week
when we're supposed to give thanks hey
England and Australia and Sweden
yeah well throw Denmark in there too
what's up there Ireland where do you say
there Madagascar do you guys have any
sort of week like that we have a big
feast what about the Irish you guys got
to have some big thing that you know
turns into some sort of drunken brawl uh
Jesus Christ can you go with any more
hacky [ __ ] yeah let's go to scarlet and
then you put your [ __ ] skirts on
right you're [ __ ] scared wearing
couch um do you guys have any days like
that we're all you're supposed to do was
just sit down and eat and then they
always has to be the debbie downer who
just sits there and starts talking about
the less-fortunate you know or one of
these [ __ ] celebrities who has to do
a little public service announcement you
know during this week of Thanksgiving
let's not forget about those Colombian
miners so wherever the [ __ ] they were
from oh wait they got rescued but still
they were down in that hole for a long
time I like how this is like the one
time of year to when people of a sudden
go out and they want to feed a homeless
guy you know I had a buddy mine did that
and he went down there and they thought
that they were all gonna be [ __ ]
high-fiving him and they were actually
they actually got pissed at I'd be like
wait a [ __ ] are you the other 11 months
of the
here he's like wow that's a good point
all right that's the podcast for this
week I want to thank everybody who came
out to my shows at the Lisner auditorium
I was calling the listener the listener
Auditorium in Washington DC had an
awesome time and comics at Foxwoods if
you live in that area the New England
area you want to do a little bit of
gamblin and then see some really
high-quality comedy I saw who the [ __ ]
they've been booking they got nothing
but uh big-time acts up there it's a
great place to see a show definitely
check that out and this weekend I'm
going to be in Seattle Washington at the
come on where the [ __ ] is it
on November 27th I'm gonna be at the
Moore theatre alright and that's a huge
venue so there are tickets left so
please when you done chowin could you
please come out check out a show I would
I would love it I got a brand-new hour
of stuff Paul virzi Owen for Paul virzi
is coming to the show he's gonna be
opening up and we're hanging around an
extra day we're gonna go to the Seattle
Seahawk Kansas City chief game on Sunday
make it a [ __ ] weekend day and if
there's any good places to eat up there
if there's the place that has the best
burger or the sandwich or whatever let
me know because we're both not boozing
and we want to go check out some [ __ ]
like that all right
that is the podcast for this week god
bless all you have a happy Thanksgiving
if you're not in this country have a
happy [ __ ] Thursday all right that's
it have a great week go [ __ ] yourselves
[Music]
you